Shawn what came first the decision to
make the movie tangerine or the decision
to shoot on an iPhone the decision to
make
tangerine came longleaf or the decision
to shoot on the iPhone that was a
shooting on the iPhone was something
that we eventually got to because when
we started budgeting the film and
looking at how we're going to make this
on the limited budget that we had that
option eventually arose so I say the
idea of tangerine came long before and
also to the beauty of the iPhone being
less conspicuous than using this right I
wish that I could say that I I knew
about all the benefits that the iPhone
was going to reveal to us and yeah I
wish I knew about no I'm sorry let me
start over I I wish I I could say that I
I was going about this intentionally and
and I was going to embrace all the
benefits that the iPhone would be giving
us but quite honestly a lot of those
benefits were revealed to us while we
were shooting and and we just we just
took advantage of them and then we made
the most of what we had but but it was
it was really started from a place of
like a budgetary constraint did anyone
try to talk you out of shooting on a
knife Oh most definitely
we had many people you know when I when
I mentioned it for the first time to
some of my producers you know all the
eyebrows were being raised I mean I I
even had to can I was trying to talk
myself out of it to tell you the truth I
am and once I convinced myself then I
had to convince the rest of the crew but
we did it by doing tests we shot a lot
of tests and at one point Technicolor
was nice enough to allow us to bring
some footage over there and blow it up
on the big screen to present it to our
finance ears and our producers and just
know that this thing
hold resolution look presentable on the
big screen and it forgive me when I came
over today I was thinking that was one
of the first few films to be shot on a
feature film but apparently it's not and
and that's nothing that you've ever made
a statement on you've always write
down true I don't know how many films
have been shot on the iPhone a handful
maybe maybe maybe even two I'm not sure
but I do we never said we were one of
the I mean we never said we were the
first iPhone movie
I actually know the makers of another
one called King Kelly that came out in
2012 that was at South by Southwest it's
a wonderful movie it's it's very
different but they shot on an earlier
version of the iPhone and they were
going for a very different aesthetic but
we can say that we are the first iPhone
film shot and true scope yes because we
had the anamorphic adapters given to us
by Moondog labs oh nice okay and so how
does that work with the lens like on the
iPhone well we I first off I found them
because of a Kickstarter campaign they
were in their prototype stage and they
were trying to get money to actually get
this product up and out there right so I
reached out to them and they they were I
had to drop mark Duplass his name of
course and but they were very happy to
lend us three of their prototypes they
sent him over basically what it does is
that you're still using the iPhone lens
it's just an adapter that fits over the
lens it allows you to capture your image
anamorphic aliy so you once you when you
are actually looking at the image on the
iPhone which is basically our monitors
on set everything is squished so you
know how in the old days you would watch
film on television you're watching
Western and everything during the
credits sequence had to be squished in
order to read everything that's how
everything looked while we were shooting
we always had to imagine what the frame
would look like once it stretched out
then when you get home and you're in
post-production you get the footage on
your computer you able stretch it out
and see
the way that the final product will be
so yeah yeah it was um it was it was
interesting we radium and I radium Chung
and I we coast shot the film radium
shown with is a wonderful
cinematographer and and and solo shot my
previous film starlet we shared duties
this time just because of schedule and
also we wanted we both wanted to be
camera operators on this but anyway he
we were joking around on set about how
we had to get so used to imagining what
the final frame would look like and how
it would stretch out but then we thought
you know that's how it was done back in
the day I'm sure that's how Sergio Leone
was doing it's you know where he would
have to look at probably a squished
image they didn't have the technology to
to have monitors on set and stretch this
thing out properly I mean so it's we're
doing the same thing that people were
doing only like for 30 40 years ago so
it was fine but were there certain
things then that when you did look at
the stretched image you realize oh you
know what we need to go back and shoot
that because we missed some little vital
thing or the most part we were okay we
were okay and remember there were only a
few shots in which we had to be
incredibly accurate with framing because
the film still has sort of a docu thing
going on which allowed for a handheld
material so you know you could always be
slightly you didn't have to be
absolutely perfect there were a few
segments within the film that are that
are locked down and and in which the
framing is extremely precise and
calculated and now in those cases no we
were fine I think by the time we got to
those sections we were pretty confident
we knew what we were doing
that being said do you think you'll go
back and shoot another film on the
iPhone no no no no no well I mean you
never know where you're gonna be but I
enjoyed the experience it was fine and
I know that already in the in the in the
last year and a half you know the
technology has advanced the point where
you can already and and the app that we
used which is called filmic Pro that's
already on another version or two since
we shot and you can capture 3k on it and
so already in the year-and-a-half
advancements has taken place within the
iPhone you know filming community and
and and and and devices that I'm sorry
and apps and tools that you can actually
you know get something better than what
we got but at the same time I do fall
into the camp of if you can shoot film
shoot film that's that's me I just
haven't been able to for the last couple
films because of budget my goal is
always to try to get the budget to shoot
on celluloid again before it goes away
entirely so that's what I'm trying to do
with the next film you know but well you
never know you can never say sure I mean
if you asked me while I was making
starlet if I would be shooting the next
film on an iPhone I would be outraged I
would have you know no way in the world
I would have considered it it actually
the whole reason that this came about is
tendering in general is because for a
year and a half after starlet I was
waiting for a much bigger budget film to
happen and it was a completely different
subject matter and it was a full script
that was ready to go that we were
looking for a cast for but it's very
hard to get cast without financing and
it's very hard to get financing without
cast so we were in this terrible cycle
that kept going on for about a year and
a half until the point where I knew I
had to make something and or I would
just be sitting around for the rest of
my life so I called up Mark Duplass and
I said you know a couple years ago you
you put it out there that you would like
to executive produce a micro budget for
me is that's offer still on the table
and he said yeah what's your idea and I
said Santa Monica and Highland I think
you might know the intersection he said
yeah yeah get me a treatment and we'll
talk about it
so just real quickly when when you
realize that this other one may not
happen because you were caught in this
weird zone what was that like before you
said you know what I I need to get
something going here fast like what do
you go through well to tell you the
truth it came down to two things I
looked at a lot of filmmakers around me
who were being quite prolific at the
time in particular I I looked at the
cinema of like Joe Swanberg and I just
was very impressed with how fast he was
making films also the Korean director
Kim ki-duk he was just seem to have one
every year and so I thought you know
that they're there because they were so
prolific they've actually they've gotten
attention for this and and the people
who weren't making things worse are
slowly falling off the radar and I felt
I was slowly falling off the radar so
this was a a desperate move for me to to
continue working number one and number
two I went to UM I was I was still on
the tail end of the starlet festival run
because you know that can actually run
up to two years sometimes you know it's
really because you'll still get requests
from film festivals almost two years
down the line and so and I love to
travel with film festivals it's very
important to me because making these
independent films there really isn't any
money in these nice movies and the
compensation for me is travel and seeing
the world anyway I got to go to New
Zealand wonderful Film Festival
absolutely like wonderful programming
because there shortly after can so they
get a lot of the canned titles so I'm
there just for two weeks watching all
these moves but then I started watching
all of course that you know the big
canned titles but then all of a sudden I
found myself also watching a lot of the
smaller independence like a lot of the
Australian Indies and and and they were
made for very little and and I thought
you know these these are inspiring me
you know why
another small film I mean I was I was
looking there were a lot of first and
second time films and this selection and
and I which I just loved how it seemed
like there was that spirit that these
filmmakers had with their films of like
just getting out there for the first
time in doing it no matter what no
matter you know with the very little
money they had and I thought you know
that's basically I'm on my fifth film
but still I'm I'm I have to retain that
spirit or I'll die so it was it was that
it was at the New Zealand Film Festival
that I remember making the decision
saying I'm gonna go back to the States
and I'm going to now focus on a whole
new project and that's why I give the
entire staff at in New Zealand Film
Festival thanks in the end credits of
tangerine
you